how do you move away from work-life
balance and start to think of work-life
integration it seems like this is
something we need to give thought to as
working from home becomes the new norm
and you've been working from home for a
while but you do the thing that I do but
just differently but you have a separate
place to work yeah I think that's one of
the keys right yeah yeah I mean I think
that's really important I think it's
having boundaries around when you're
working and when you're not because when
you work from home you can just always
be working and even when you're not
really working you're kind of working
and it just bleeds into everything and
then you're not present for anything in
your life that isn't work-related right
yeah so so the work/life balance thing I
mean to me it's more like the work-life
integration right and that's what Chris
is saying here and I I think it's much
harder if everything is integrated if
you're working and having a family and
having dinners and everything's at home
right now everything it becomes the stew
and you can't you there's a balance
within the stew it's all sort of
integrated right and so I find the way
that I mean the reason we're in a
co-working space is it's easier for me
to be able to come here and do the thing
you if I'm writing a book or or whatever
but it also it sets up a trigger a
creative environment for me where I feel
different in that space and even we were
trying to do the zoom thing from home
for a little while here we had three
podcast episodes on Zen caster it was it
felt wrong because it was also in my
home like the environment felt wrong as
well it wasn't just the lack of face to
face but I'm used to this environment
now yeah but now everybody is at home
right and they and they can't go to a
co-working space can't even go to
Starbucks and and get away from the
house like if you're compelled to work
at home now a lot of people are
grappling with what those rules look
like in order to like maintain some kind
of sanity when they're doing zoom calls
in their living room like all day and
their toddler is you know chewin at
their ankle yeah and there may be
boundaries you can set up like I've
heard seth godin talk about he uses two
different machines like he'll use a
laptop and a whole really old ratty
laptop to write on and then if he wants
to surf the web he has like a tablet
and like a Faraday machine disconnect
you from the internet right Shirley for
writing Jonathan Franzen does then he
cut off
he cut the ethernet cable and glued it
in superglue yeah yeah and and I mean
there are things you can do I've done
experiments where I I have my wife hide
the Wi-Fi password from me and so like
there are things you can do that that
set up those boundaries but I also I
think there's a physical environment
boundary so it could even be that you
have a tiny desk on top of your laundry
your washing machine and that's the
place you've decided to work I mean
that's like the the Stephen King you
know wrote in a closet for a while or
whatever it feels to be like setting up
that separate space even within your
home could be the trigger that you're
working as opposed to I don't letting
the work bleed out into them 24 hours of
the day yeah yeah and it's simple
practices too just because you're at
home doesn't mean you should just be in
pajamas like all day every day you know
like you know create some structure and
you know build some habits into you know
how you're approaching every day so your
intentional about it rather than just
pretending like you're you know at home
sick for three months